Prof: We're discussing
the fertility transition and
we've talked that prior to the
fertility transition there was
control of fertility,
but it was at a very high level.
In different parts of the world
we talked in very general terms
about it.
I want to just describe a
little bit about what the story
was in Europe,
exactly how fertility was
controlled.
One of the main reasons,
I mentioned this before,
but didn't really describe it,
is control of marriage.
That the number of people that
were allowed to,
and in some sense,
get married changed with
economic conditions and
agricultural conditions.
You can see that very clearly
wherever you get statistics from
the period.
As you know,
the first year of the Black
Death was 1347-1348,
and huge numbers of people died
and their land was immediately
taken over by someone else.
Immediately these new
landowners got married.
There was an enormous burst of
marriage.
Like in one small French
village there had been 10 to 12
marriages a year in the
preceding decade.
In 1349, the first year after
that phase of the plague passed
it went from 10 to 12,
to 86 marriages,
an enormous thing.
What was going on is there
was--before the Black Death when
Europe was crowded for its
system there was a huge pool of
unmarried individuals who really
wanted to get married,
but did not have any land on
which to support themselves or a
family and the opening of the
land allows marriage to take
place.
Then not only did they get
married right away,
but the women got pregnant
immediately,
and one contemporary observer
wrote,
"There are pregnant women
wherever you look."
This is 1349.
Up--this fertility rate was a
flexible system that moved up
and down according to economic
and demographic conditions.
In England, there's data from
the 1550s and later,
the gross reproduction rate,
that's the number of women--
there are a certain number of
women in one generation how many
female children do they produce?
In the 1550s it was 2.8,
so one will reproduce a woman,
the gross reproduction rate
will be one, but they were
producing 2.8.
A century later it drops down
to 1.8 and that's the 1650s,
and by 1880s it rises again to
over three,
so there's enormous range
between one,
close to one,
less than two,
just reproducing themselves
getting into this dangerous
thing where--
with the very high death rates,
where the whole society at that
rate won't continue--
and a factor of three women
which will do just fine.
You can see the same thing at
the age of marriage,
not only the numbers of
marriage of course but the age
of marriage.
During the early 1800s remember
that was a time when the
American food is there,
European population was rising,
strong as a high birth rate so
land hunger became--
land--there was no extra land
available so marriage became
later and later,
and eventually reached 23 to 28
for females and even older than
that for males.
By that time probably the
average lifespan was 35,
it had improved some,
but if you're fertile at say 15
and you don't marry until 28,
that's a huge chunk of your
reproductive life where you're
not reproducing,
that reduces the birth rate and
keeps the population in check.
However, once in marriage,
the children just flowed.
There was no--apparently no
control within marriage
whatsoever.
In 300 years--all the data that
we have says that in 300 years
in Europe there was no control
of fertility within marriage,
all the control,
all the social control of
population was in how many
people got married,
what they called the nuptiality;
the fraction of people that got
married was the total mechanism
of social control.
There's of course external
control by disease,
by famines because some plague
of the plants,
and then there were individual
controls which we've talked
about infanticide and so forth.
In terms of social controls,
the northwestern--
the Northern Europeans,
especially northwestern
European model was controlled
marriage and it was quite
effective.
These marriage controls didn't
just happen automatically,
people just didn't sort of have
a rational sense that said,
'Oh I can't get married.'
There was really--the controls
were forced upon them.
Most land was owned by some
landowner and the man was given
a plot of land which he could
work.
It was the size so that one
individual could work this plot
of land.
He starts having children.
Well the landlord knows that
only one son is needed to farm
that land,
and the father knows he can
only give that land to one son,
so there's tremendous pressure
if you have extra children they
can't stay at home.
You'll see when we talk about
China a very different model.
He can't stay at home,
those people are forced off to
the cities,
and in the cities are very
dangerous and disease ridden
places,
so they just die in the cities,
and the cities are growing this
time but very high death rates
still in the cities.
About one-third,
each generation had to be
replenished as I've mentioned to
you, but about one-third in the
cities.
The landlord of course didn't
want these extra children around
because he would have more and
more people to feed with the
same amount of land therefore
the same amount of production.
You had to get the landlord's
permission in order to get
married and if you didn't--if he
didn't have extra land for you,
you couldn't get married.
Of course officially it wasn't
the landlord but it was the
local parish church that you had
to get married in,
but guess who hired the parish
minister or priest?
The local landlord,
and the whole structure of
churches almost everywhere is
that they are very much either
controlled by or mutual support
of the gentry,
the rich people and the
religious authorities intermix.
They weren't allowed to get
married either by the landlord
or by the church.
It was very--you had to post
what they called banns so
everybody knew there was a
marriage,
and of course the landlord
would notice,
and so it was impossible to do
anything about that.
Another mechanism was going off
and becoming a servant that was
one of the very standard kinds
of things.
They would leave home very
young become a servant and--
males and females both servants
in the houses,
you've all seen these Victorian
movies and earlier movies,
how many servants they have.
Of course they were never
allowed to get married,
not allowed to have sex,
no boyfriend,
no girlfriend,
none of that was allowed--
very, very strict rules on
house servants and house
servants were a very large
faction of the young people--
of everybody in, say, England.
Then those that didn't become
servants would go off and become
an apprentice.
One son stays at home,
the others go off and become
apprentices,
and apprenticeship was a very
long period of time in which
they had to learn the skills and
get some sort of resources so
that they could buy the
equipment and rent the shop and
set up eventually on their own,
or wait until the master died
and then inherit the master's
place.
The end result of all this is
that it took many,
many years to establish a
sufficient economic base so that
the society would allow you to
get married.
Many people never got married;
I'll show you a little bit
later what the marriage rates
actually were in Europe during
this period, and its
surprisingly low.
The culture adapts to this.
What do all these unmarried men
and women do?
We have the spinster woman;
we have the confirmed bachelor,
again you've seen men in much
British comedy and British
movies about--
always has characters in it
where some confirmed bachelor,
he's just not getting married.
Presumably a fair amount of the
homosexuality that was present,
especially in the British upper
classes is due to this whole
tradition that a lot of males
are not going to get married,
and then they do something with
their sexual impulse.
Of course that's not proven;
we don't really understand the
basis of homosexuality.
Females were also,
like the males,
forced off the land,
if they were not the wife of
the one son that inherited the
land,
they had to go somewhere else
so they went to the cities where
there were not jobs,
especially not jobs for women
so they become sort of a
floating population,
very largely prostitutes--huge
explosion of prostitution at
this time both because of the
excess women that are trying to
stay alive that have migrated
into the cities,
and there's all these bachelors
there having some sort of job
that could pay for their
services.
Of course you know that babies
that resulted from any of these
situations were very often just
abandoned and left to die.
This control of marriage,
that marriage was the control,
the social control on
population lasted well into the
1800s,
well into and possibly even
through the Victorian era.
These mechanisms together
reduced the north European
birthrate, and especially in
England, to about 50% of what it
otherwise could have been.
Remember we did calculations of
how many children one can have,
and then there's always
examples much to the high end of
that.
But in England taking a
reasonable number,
these controls of marriage cut
the birthrate in half.
What did it feel like to the
people involved in this?
I suspect a fair number of you
have heard this quote.
It's a letter from a woman to
her uncle.
Don't shout out but raise your
hand if you know it.
"I think dearest uncle
that you cannot really wish me
to be the mother of a numerous
family,
for I think you will see the
great inconvenience in a large
family would be the hardship to
myself.
Men never think what a hard
task it is for us women to go
through this pregnancy very
often."
Have you heard this?
No, no one's heard this letter,
it's very famous.
This is a woman in this
situation.
She's married,
and therefore she's having
children one after the other
with no kind of control,
and she's complaining,
'this is hard on me and why
don't you men ever think how
hard this is on me?'
What social class,
is this a poor woman,
middle class woman,
upper class woman?
Having all this--no ideas;
it's Queen Victoria.
Here's by far the richest woman
in the world,
has all the help,
all the money,
all the food,
and, even for her,
it's a burden and she probably
doesn't have to do much of the
burden except handle the
pregnancy and childbearing,
and if she perceives it as a
burden,
then can you imagine what the
common woman thinks of it.
By the way, it's Queen Victoria
to her uncle who is King Leopold
of Belgium, you've heard this
before.
When sexuality itself since--a
lot of problems with sexuality
at that time.
You've been reading some stuff
about it,
and one of the things is that
men, aside from the childbirth
aspect of it that women were of
course always worried that if
they had sex they would get
pregnant and often they didn't--
usually they did not want to
get pregnant,
but also the men were not very
skilled.
They either did not know how to
pleasure a woman,
they didn't want to,
or they thought it was very
improper to even try to pleasure
a woman.
Here's another quote from Lady
Alice Huntington--
Hillingdon--1857,
she died only in 1940 so we're
really coming up to fairly
recent kinds of times,
and presumably,
this was written in her journal
in 1912.
No one can find that journal so
they don't know the state of--
how apocryphal this is,
but this is a quote that again
you've probably heard,
at least part of it.
"I am happy now that
George,"
her husband,
"calls on my bedchamber
less frequently then of old.
As it is, I now endure but two
calls a week and,
when I hear his steps outside
my door,
I lie down upon my bed,
close my eyes,
open my legs and think of
England."
Sometimes the quote is,
"think of Victoria,"
but apparently think of England
is the proper--
again we're not talking about
some poor woman with a brutal
husband,
as in some Oliver Twist movies,
this is a very high status
lady.
How did this change and who was
arrayed against this?
People, women especially,
were not happy with the
situation.
Young men of course wanted to
get married,
couldn't until they were old,
and we've talked about that
situation in Africa where the
bride price is very high,
the old men control the bride
price,
they don't allow the young men
to get married until there's
almost a revolution.
This is an aside,
but with respect to the bride
price, we hear a lot about older
men marrying or having sex with
younger women.
In the West it's one of the
things we sort of complain
about,
about other cultures that this
great disparity in age--
an older man with a younger
woman.
We tend to blame the man who's
getting married,
but if you think of it from the
point of view of their society,
that man has been under the
control of even older guys,
the really powerful guys,
and so he's been abused and not
allowed to get married until
he's old.
The women of his age are
already married to the much
older guys so this is his only
option.
Again, within a society these
things all intermingle and form
a pattern,
not necessarily a good pattern,
not necessarily a pattern that
the people like,
but it is a tight web.
Coming back to Europe,
there was this unfortunate
situation where young men
weren't allowed to get married,
young women weren't allowed to
get married,
once you're in marriage the
sexual mores were so straight
jacketed that it was not
pleasurable for most of the
women apparently,
and who knows what the men were
using,
the Victorian pornography
during this period is lots of
mistresses,
lots of prostitution and lots
of being whipped.
They loved to get punished
themselves, which is a
surprising preponderance of
masochistic sexuality in the
Victorian literature of that
time.
At least from our point of
view, sexuality was a mess.
So some people tried to change
this,
of course there's always
pioneers, and in England one of
the pioneers was a man and a
woman,
Charles Bradlaugh and Annie
Besant.
In 1877 family planning
was--contraception was coming
into possibility in England and
so they distributed--
printed and distributed what we
would now consider a very mild
pamphlet about birth control
called,
The Fruits of Philosophy.
It was very abstract and
philosophical.
Of course what happened to them?
Arrested, indicted,
and the official indictment
accused them of 'inciting and
encouraging the subjects of the
Queen to indecent,
obscene, unnatural,
and immoral practices,
and to bring them,' the
citizens of the Queen,
the subjects of the Queen,
'to a state of wickedness,
lewdness, and debauchery.'
This is because they were
saying that--well there's these
things called condoms around and
why don't you use them.
This trial was very interesting
in that in a culture there's
certain things you can't talk
about.
If something is culturally
forbidden, like almost anything
to do with sex in marriage,
you just couldn't talk about
it.
Now here's this big trial in
London, very famous,
all the newspapers are carrying
it, and guess what everybody
learns about?
Birth control;
and a very big thing and some
scholars,
some historians
attribute--there's just the
period when the use of birth
control is increasing
tremendously in England,
-- and that this trial
popularized it.
What did we have something
similar a few years ago in
America with our President?
Bill Clinton and oral sex,
are you all too young to--
that was a taboo topic,
you could not discuss it and
then the right wing,
the conservatives who were
opposed to this kind of free
sexual activity publicized it
and publicized,
and publicized it until every
teenager in America knew about
oral sex and now the data is
that oral sex has just gone
exponentially down into the high
schools and even junior high
schools.
I could tell you stories about
that, but I won't.
With all this moralizing about
it that the religious leaders,
the political leaders,
the medical doctors said it was
bad for you,
you've read some of that in
your reading,
everybody is--they were
terrorized in a sense.
There was an intellectual
terrorization of the people,
they feared legal prosecution.
Most of these things were
illegal, to buy things,
to use things,
to write about them,
to publish them.
They were told that they would
get physical injury.
You may have heard that
masturbation will make you blind
and that--I don't know if any of
your parents said that but I
heard it in my time.
Mental injury,
if it doesn't make you blind,
it'll make you crazy,
and deep moral reservations and
just straight aesthetic distaste
that when the society frowns on
something we sort of have
incorporated a kind of revulsion
to anything which society
considers disgusting,
and contraceptives themselves
were considered repulsive,
unnatural, only for
prostitutes, that kind of thing.
Of course, at that time,
almost--a lot of people were
starting to do it,
but since you couldn't talk
about it publicly,
no one knew what everyone else
was doing so they thought they
had to take this great leap
themselves in defiance of
everything that their culture is
telling them.
How did it--what happened an
individual's starting to think
about these things.
We have some interesting--a lot
of interesting stuff referred to
in the reading.
Some of this in your reading is
letters to various pioneers,
Margaret Sanger or who was it
in England the--
I'm blocking on the name of the
clinic in England .
We have letters from women sort
of begging information on how to
keep from getting pregnant
again.
A lot of it is not with any
official organizations,
just women talking to women,
and some of it can be relaxed
at a little bit later stage.
There's a series of nice
interviews from the 1920s and
1930s with elderly Italian and
Jewish women in the United
States.
They talked to each other about
technique,
because techniques is one of
the things,
and this interview is from an
Italian American woman born in
the U.S.
in 1920, recent immigrant
parents, and the conversation
took place in the late 1930s.
She works in a hair dressing
salon and she gets engaged,
and of course all her coworkers
know about it,
and so an interviewer--an
anthropologist--
a sociologist--goes in and
starts asking her about it.
Apparently prior to this little
quote they had brought up the
topic of birth control so the
interviewer says,
"How did you learn about
condoms?"
Nina: "One of my customers
said, 'I really hope you don't
get pregnant,
let him wear a raincoat.'
So I started wondering,
I'm thinking,
I'm working and my mind just
can't work out what a raincoat
is."
Then Mary White who worked for
me said, "Baby what's on
your mind?
I said, "Mrs. Jacobs
said a funny thing to me,
she said my ring was
lovely,"
her marriage ring,
"but she hoped I didn't
start a family and he should
wear a raincoat.
But I can't ask Johnny to wear
a raincoat to bed."
This Mary White laughed and
laughed and says,
"She means he's to wear a
condom."
"What is it?"
Nina said.
And then she got told and got
enlightened in this and it's
that kind of conversation where
individual people of not very
high class are learning that
it's okay to buck the trend and
even the basic information they
previously don't have.
It doesn't always work out
that, when these discussions
take place,
that the participants do take
on the new behavior,
sometimes they don't want to do
that.
Gossip--most conversation by
humans is gossip and there's
very good studies showing this.
We know that from our chimps
days we're a very social
species,
that status is so terribly
important and status translates
to social acceptability,
so the purpose of gossip is to
find out what the limits of
social acceptability are.
Gossip is almost exclusively
about someone who has stepped
over what was perceived to be
the limit and either gotten away
with it or not gotten away with
it,
or something that's now just
inside the limit.
A large fraction of gossip is
to see what is socially
acceptable in my circle,
and sometimes like we've seen
here,
the use of condoms becomes
socially acceptable as a result
of discussions like this.
Sometimes it--at least this
individual at this time it
doesn't become acceptable.
Where is this other quote that
I'm looking for?
This is another two women,
and the interviewer asks,
"How did your friends have
abortions?"
The issue of abortions came up
and as you probably have read or
will read,
abortions at this time were
very, very common,
all illegal, but very common.
"Peggy,
I'm trying to think what they
would take because they'd tell
me,
a lot of them would have a
friend who would put something
up there that would bring on
their period."
The interviewer,
"A knitting needle?"
Peggy, "No not a knitting
needle,
some kind of fluid,
like hot boiling water or salt
water,
they would ruin their insides,
they would say,
'Oh Peggy don't you do that.'
Oh no I would never do that,
that's my husband,
it's the man who takes
care."
It's interesting that in this
particular case it's usually the
woman's responsibility in most
cases,
but in this case whatever was
going on in the marriage she
perceived it as the husband's
case,
and in further discussion that
it was his responsibility to use
a condom all the time.
The reason given by the woman
is not any moral consideration,
no life--that's not the
consideration,
but it's a medical thing,
it's just at that time the
methods since it was illegal,
and if you didn't--even if you
went to a practitioner it was
very,
very dangerous but the kinds of
things that women actually used
on themselves were so incredibly
dangerous,
so the reason she's not having
an abortion is that she doesn't
want to ruin herself in the
medical sort of way.
You take this same woman,
transpose her 50 years later,
where now abortion is safe and
possibly legal,
this same woman may have a very
different attitude toward,
but of course we don't know
anything about that.
The point of this--series of
stories is a big change in
culture,
that prior--every society has
to control population in some
way and we've talked about the
physical constraints,
the disease and famines,
we've talked about the social
controls like not being able to
get married,
but up until--in Europe up
until very recently there was no
individual control.
Individuals themselves did not
have the cultural freedom to
make these kinds of decisions.
Once married,
procreation just keeps going
one after the other until either
someone dies or the woman
becomes infertile.
Now we're seeing a transition
where individuals can start
deciding for themselves,
a very big change in the
extension of agency that what a
person thinks they can control
about their lives.
Here is an elderly Jewish
woman, who was talking about her
mother and said the way the
neighbors now start controlling
this,
so the mother who did not use
any kind of fertility control,
her friends and relatives would
sort of get on her case but
mild,
chided her mildly.
When she would get pregnant
they would say,
'Oh!, Esther not another
belly,' and so at this time
friends,
relatives, neighbors start
imposing a new culture on you.
There's some aspects of freedom
that the individual now gets to
choose but the culture comes on
and now at least starts to
import a new cultural norm on
you.
In Sicily, reputed to have very
high,
actually having high fertility
rates,
but at some point they go
through their transition and
this is in 1980--
in the 1980s,
very late, and this is a report
of woman who's one of the few
remaining peasants in this
village.
Sicily, like all the rest of
the world, is changing and
growing up.
She reported that these
families that still had child
after child, after child,
their neighbors called them
animals.
And this is Sicilian to
Sicilian.
Here's another example of this,
a Jewish immigrant in the U.S.
writing to her mother back in
Poland.
This is a lovely letter.
"Here in America,
it is the custom that if a
woman wants to she has a baby,
and if she does not want to
have any, she doesn't.
David's wife,
I don't know if that's a
brother or something,
"David's wife says that
she will have a baby every four
years.
I think it is good to have one
every three years,
and so after three years I
shall have another.
It is terrible that at home
women suffer only hardships in
childbearing."
Home being Poland in this case.
It's really interesting that
the technology is not of
interest to her.
She doesn't--in this case talk
about the wonderful new
contraceptives that they have in
America which of course they
would not have had in Poland.
Nor about the availability
of--the knowledge about it,
the availability of it,
the technology of it,
she doesn't talk about
economics.
She doesn't say,
'Oh we can't afford it or we
can afford,' any of that sort of
stuff.
She talks about what to her is
this startling new idea that's
under her control,
that she can choose herself
what to do,
and someone else can make a
different kind of a choice.
What she's exuberant about is
the lack of cultural
constraints;
she's now a free individual to
navigate the world as she sees
it in herself.
Also in all these discussions
men are rarely mentioned,
it really is sort of women's
decision here,
and the women are working it
out, and again in most of these
things--
well in a lot of these things
sometimes it is the man,
'no matter what I say he won't
stay away from me,' but once the
contraception comes in then men
want the sex and you get a lot
of conflict if they're using
contraception,
but once contraception comes in
it seems to be much easier to
manage the females.
You have read some of this in
your readings.
Until the demographic--so now
I'm going to go back to talking
about marriage--
until the demographic
revolution as I said,
the marriages rates are
controlled by the community not
the individual.
Let's look at the marriage
rates here if I can find them
without--
this is Belgium and various
provinces in Belgium,
and Belgium as you know is a
totally Catholic country,
and we will talk a little bit
more about Belgium in a minute.
Here are the dates from before
the transition to 1970,
very recent.
This is the marital index,
what fraction got married and
look at that 40%,
only 40% of people got married
in that year--
that ever married,
so more than half of people are
not getting married.
We think of the old days as
everybody had to get married.
No.
As time goes on,
as the fertility transition
takes place as people are having
fewer and fewer children within
marriage,
the marriage rate goes up
drastically until it's 70%,
75%, which is kind of a modern
rate.
The same thing,
this is another set of
provinces,
another set of provinces,
there's Antwerp,
the big cities,
Luxemburg which--a lot of
provinces in Belgium.
A very interesting thing is
that, again keeping in mind that
societies have to control their
fertility.
If you're controlling marriage,
if you don't have any mechanism
of contraception then when
people get married they're going
to have babies boom,
boom, boom, boom so you have to
control one method,
you have to control the number
of marriages,
so you control it extremely,
40% marriages.
In China--we're going to talk
about China later--
do you know what the rate
of--the Americans complain and
Chinese too to some degree about
the one child policy and the
excess of female --
of males--that there aren't
enough girls to get married and
this is going to cause
incredible social disruption.
You know what the rate--what
the absence of females is there?
At maximum like 15% or 18% and
so nothing like--here 60% of
people aren't getting married.
The Chinese situation is still
above--if all the males--if all
the females get married
something like 85% of men can
get married.
If you compare China and
Europe, it's again,
it's not necessarily a reality
based thing this worry about the
male/female ratio.
This is a map of Europe,
and the whole of Europe
including Russia,
and this is 1870 and it was
1870 Europe,
this was from the Princeton
project and every one of these
little things is a province of
Europe,
and every one these provinces
they've collected data on
everything under the sun for,
and this is the marriage rate.
Look here, the red is less than
30% and you have an occasional
place,
northern Scotland,
I think is--it's not Bulgaria,
Bulgaria is more over here,
I can't tell from the map but
it's a province in the south
here.
Look at the red here,
that's under 40% of people are
getting married and then some of
the lighter stuff you get into
the 40% to 50%.
The same true through middle
Europe: Germany,
Austria, Switzerland,
Scandinavia,
Finland.
All through here they're all in
the 50% and less,
less than 50% of people are
getting married.
1870--a little bit in Spain you
get up into a more reasonable
range and you have to go all the
way out to the Caspian Sea,
the border of the Caspian Sea
to find people getting married,
80% of the people getting
married, a number that we
consider something sort of
reasonable for our--
not now because marriage rate
is falling but that was the
general preconception of
Westerners growing up in our
society is that from time
immemorial almost everybody got
married,
but it's not the case.
The Eastern Europe,
which was in a rather different
mold, had a higher marriage
rate.
Now you look at this,
this is 1870 and you come up to
after the fertility transition
and look what happens,
everybody's gone bluish.
Marriage has just shot up all
over Europe, including--which is
actually what you've got left;
these are sort of doing the
reverse, but Western Europe
where we have lots of lots of
good data and understanding
there's almost nothing pink
left.
Guess now who has the lowest
marriage rate?
Ireland.
What's special about Ireland at
this time?
Catholic and no contraception
so they're not allowed to get
married.
They're back in the 30%,
40% and that's sort of very
characteristic of the sociology
of Ireland.
That the men are very close to
their mother and get married
either very late or don't get
married at all.
Whereas England,
their Protestant neighbor,
sharing all kinds of other
cultural aspects is up there in
the 70% to 75% of marriage,
so that's one of the really
amazing kinds of things that
happened that basically the
spread of marriage;
that in Europe--different story
in other parts of the world
that--
because of the need to control
total population in the old days
people just weren't allowed to
get married because once they
were in marriage they weren't
allowed to use contraception.
Once you flip that equation and
open up to individual decision,
there's no requirement--that in
all of this there's no
requirement to use contraception
but families naturally want to
have fewer children then they
would have naturally and so
fertility in a family declines.
The social control of marriage
is not needed anymore and the
marriage rate goes up very high.
Of course along with marriage
that--I call this a
democratization effect,
marriage gets democratized and
of course sex gets democratized.
Prior to this,
all these people that aren't
married either have no sex,
or they have homosexual sex,
they go to prostitutes,
I mean they--we don't know much
about how much sex they had but
they had some sort of sex,
and that was what society
demanded of them.
Normal marital sex was not
allowed and a small fraction
were able to get married and
have sex--
so along with the
democratization of marriage you
also get the democratization of
sex.
Let's look at some of the
details of this happening.
While I've got these pictures,
these big maps are hard for the
computer to calculate
apparently.
This is some the contraceptives
that were coming at this time.
Some of these--there's several
museums in the world that get
all the contra--
one is just stones,
putting stones in the--
other sort of various forms of
blocking the canal to absorb the
semen,
and you put cotton or something
in a little bag like this,
put it in the vagina and--these
all helped.
This, I don't know exactly what
that is, but again some blocking
substance, then they could be
made not only of vegetable
matter, but of metal.
There's a whole bunch of things
called pessaries where the
cap--a cap made out of porcelain
or something is put over the
cervix.
There are--this is a variety of
condoms,
including some fairly modern
ones, but the older ones--
this is an old way they were
made--older ones looked like
this and what do you think was--
how they originally made
condoms?
The technology was borrowed
from something else.
What else comes very commonly
purchased item come--sausages,
exactly.
What was--before there was
plastics what was sausage casing
made out of?
Intestines, animal intestines,
they can be made very thin
because they're just a small
barrier for absorption,
very thin and so they were
called skins and I don't know
which of these things are which,
but that was not a very
difficult technology to make
them out of skins.
Here are some more modern
things, various kinds of IUDs,
everything under the sun was
tried, including the more
modern.
This is a very ancient
technique.
People at different times have
believed that almost anything
works as a contraceptive,
this is a bone on a string,
again placed inside,
and heaven knows what the
theory was why that would work.
It might have just prevented
the man from entering far enough
or something,
who knows.
The string, like a modern IUD,
whereas a string hangs out and
you can pull it down.
One of the problems with modern
IUDs until recently,
and the same problem here,
you have a string and what does
the string do?
It's a route for bacteria to
swim up so the strings are
dangerous things.
Let me get back to the
beginning of this a little bit.
Now we've talked about
individuals sort of in a variety
of ways how this happened to
individuals and cultural things.
Here--you didn't--this wasn't
in your reading this particular
graph.
So here is a graph of the date,
again Europe,
the different countries of
Europe and when--
within marriage what their rate
of fertility was within
marriage,
with actually 1.0 being the
Hutterite level which is the
maximum level people have
achieved.
What do you make out of that?
It's kind of a mess, right?
You can see something,
you can see France being lower
already by 1860,
we know it had its transition
and you can't really see much
else.
One of the data that you read
about,
if you take those same graphs
and now change their time thing
and ask,
well let's gather each graph at
the point--
there's a traditional level of
fertility,
eight or so children,
and in each country it may be a
little different somewhere
between six and eight,
and then at some point it
starts to drop and when it's
dropped by 10% is a critical
stage,
so the Princeton people argued,
and so they've gathered--
this is the years after
reaching the 90%,
so at this point in time all of
these countries have dropped.
These curves are gathered to
put together the point where
they reach 10% drop from their
pre-transition level.
Then it makes more sense.
Look at the way it falls down
like crazy until it hits some
sort of roughly a new plateau at
about half or so of the earlier
plateau,
a little bit less than half.
The amount of time here,
this is zero years and it's all
over maybe in 50 years,
and if you look at any one
place it's a much shorter period
than that.
Within a very--what Princeton
decided a couple of things.
One that's hard to figure out
but there was,
for some reason,
various groups started their
fertility decline and we'll talk
about various theories of that,
but once it became--whereas
everyone else was horrified
about whatever they say,
it was rich people,
it was outcast people.
How did in--so it was upper
class--the fertility decline
happened first among upper
class,
among city class,
among Jews, and so it's always
some sort of a non-majority
social group that starts social
change.
What made the discussion of
condoms legitimate?
In America when I was in--you
could not mention condom,
no television discussion of it,
news reports never mentioned
it,
and what is it that allowed
condoms to be discussed in
America?
You know--AIDS epidemic,
and where did the AIDS epidemic
start in?
Homosexuals,
so a marginalized group starts
something, it spreads into the
culture.
Where do our clothing fashions
often come from?
From the poorest kids often,
I can see--
go into the ghetto and see what
the kids are wearing and six
years later you guys are going
to be wearing exactly what
they're wearing,
long baggy pants and so forth
and showing various parts.
The idea is one,
that something happens up here
and there's a lot of discussion
about that but once it becomes
socially--
the idea is that once it
reaches that 10% level,
it just falls down,
fertility just falls down like
a stone.
In this period,
up here you can get all kinds
of economic levels,
that different economic groups
are having different fertility,
different educational groups,
difference between urban and
rural,
difference in whether they're
agricultural or in an industry,
and you can find all these
differences,
but once this fertility thing
starts like this,
everybody does it.
What they call these
differentials,
these socio economic
differentials just disappear and
a farmer is just as likely to be
limiting his fertility as a
bourgeois person in the cities.
If you try to think of how
rapidly the economic situation
changes,
or how rapidly does education
increase,
and you look at all the various
variables,
none of them increase with this
kind of rapidity,
none of them change with that
kind of ability,
infant mortality,
almost anything you can
measure,
nothing goes with that kind of
a rate.
What goes with that kind of a
rate?
A fad, a fashion.
If you look all around Europe,
and this was in your reading,
what you see is the date of the
beginning of the decade.
This is the decade where that
10% level was reached and what
provinces are this?
This is all France.
Then there's a long delay,
a surprisingly long delay,
and boom all the rest of Europe
then does it in basically--
most of it's done between 1870
and 1930,
it's almost all done.
This just sweeps through
Europe, and again as I've showed
you on the maps,
it includes Russia,
Eastern Europe,
economically and educationally
very underdeveloped kinds of
places,
and yet the fertility drops,
this is all of Europe,
nobody is left out.
Again, it makes it difficult to
put an economic or an
educational, any of these other
variables on it.
What you have instead is,
and one of these stories you
read about in your reading--
remember that each of these
graduate students and post docs
was put on a different country
of Europe in the Princeton
project.
One had to do England,
one had to do--
and have the who did England is
going to be guest lecturer here
next week,
next Thursday,
he's not going to talk about
that because you'll have had
enough of that by then.
There was a guy who was
assigned Spain;
this guy is William Leisure,
and this I think you read a
little bit about.
He gathered all this data,
a huge amount of work in all
the Spanish archives of every
province from going way back to
1830 or something,
whatever was there,
he looked at.
And he put it all together and
he could not make any sense out
of it whatsoever.
This guy was going out of his
mind and he took to drawing a
map of fertility rates,
sort of like those kinds of
maps I just showed you,
fertility rates at different
points in time in the different
provinces of Spain.
He showed it to everybody and
apparently he was walking around
campus one day and he saw a
professor of Spanish Literature
who he had met somewhere and he
said he buttonholed the guy and
showed him these graphs and
said,
'I can't make any sense out of
this,' and he told the professor
what it was.
The professor said,
'That's the linguistic regions
of Spain.'
As you know Spain had a variety
of kingdoms,
they were controlled by the
Muslims,
and then the Northern
Christians kicked them out,
but there's Castille and
Navarra, and Aragon and all of
these cultural things.
And still the Basques consider
themselves quite separate,
the Catalans consider
themselves separate,
so Spain, to this day,
has serious regional
diversities.
What apparently Leisure had
come up with unknowingly was a
map of the linguistic boundaries
of ancient medieval Spain and
they still remained.
The idea that he came up with,
as well as is fairly obvious,
is that people that could speak
the same language,
the same dialect,
were of the common culture
would talk to each other and
that it was social spread what
kept the province,
a linguistic region uniform in
its fertility practices was the
cultural spread,
but that was the cultural unit
as well as the linguistic unit
and it didn't cross boundaries.
Another more quantified example
of that is Belgium and here is
Belgium, in Belgium they speak
two languages which are?
French and Flemish,
and Flemish is almost the same
as?
Dutch, which is almost the same
German, so it's a big divide,
it's a Germanic/Romance
language divide.
This is a big language divide
and in Belgium here are the
various provinces of Belgium,
and these are the southern ones
near--
France is over here--so these
are all French speaking and
Holland is up there,
and Germany is over here--these
are the Flemish speaking
provinces.
When you look at their
fertility what happens is that--
when you look at their
fertility France is,
as you've heard 100 times,
starts the fertility
transition,
fertility drops there.
It goes--it takes a fair amount
of time but it goes first into
French speaking Belgium and
French speaking Belgium then
conforms to the French norm.
Then there's this language line
and you compare across that line
and nothing north of the line
changes and it takes 60 years to
cross that language line that I
showed you.
It takes 60 takes to cross the
language barrier.
This guy Lesthaeghe,
the guy who studied--
who was assigned to Belgium,
and he is Belgian himself,
he said well what could be
causing it,
what are the differences
between north/south aside from
language?
When he was doing it they
didn't really come up with
this--
when he was originally--when he
started it they didn't--
hadn't understood this cultural
difference and so he's looking
at socioeconomic variables.
And so he took villages across
that boundary line there,
and you take no more than five
kilometers difference and he
would take villages that were
matched: the soil was kind of
the same,
the agricultural productivity
was the same,
and every kind of socioeconomic
variable that he could find was
not different across that line
except fertility.
That the northern line just had
an awful lot more children then
south of the line,
French speaking Flemish
speaking and presumably
eliminating all these
socioeconomic variables by
comparing these neighboring
towns all across Belgium from
east to west,
all across this line he looked
at these kinds of paired
villages.
Well he said what was doing it?
Well there's--so they started
thinking about cultural reasons,
and at that time in Europe
there were two--
democracy was still
fairly--real democracy was still
fairly young but most everybody
had the vote and there was a lot
of discussion about who would
control democracy,
whether democracy was a good or
bad thing,
so the suffrage,
the expanded kind of suffrage,
they still had kings and all
that, but the power was being
eroded by parliaments and there
were two sets of parties as
really there still are in
Europe.
One was the Catholic party,
the conservative party called--
the other was the socialist
party's or the communist
party's,
and anybody know what they're
called?
The Social Democrats and there
are a variety of names other
parties--
the Christian Demo--the parties
that are still named Christian
Democrats and Social Democrats.
Like in Germany they pass the
premiership back and forth
between them.
That was established at this
time and it was considered a
fairly good marker for what we
call secularization that how
much a person was still
believing in the old morality,
the old styled things was
religious,
they would usually vote for the
Christian democrats.
People that had undergone some
sort of a transition and now
were buying socialist theory or
worker solidarity theory,
or believed in unions would
vote the Democratic Socialist
party.
What he did,
he said, 'okay let's look at
each of the provinces again,
this is a smaller grouping then
province and see what their vote
is.'
There's the Catholic party,
and this is the percentage of
non-Catholic party,
and then he just compared this
with how much their fertility
had declined,
again, always within marriage.
It turns out the more
non-Catholic they are the
greater the decline in
fertility.
It's kind of a backwards thing,
and very nice line of
proportionality.
This is an exact
proportionality and the points
stick really very close to that
line;
it's not hard to see what that
line is,
and so people--what became
clear is that culturally people
that were voting for the
Catholic party and therefore
were in the older mode of
culture did not drop their
fertility very much.
People who were voting the
socialist,
the left wing,
liberal whatever you want to
call it,
had dropped their fertility by
60% to 80%,
a huge drop in fertility.
All right, these kinds of data
kept coming up.
To conclude--the bottom line is
that in this Princeton project
they just could not tie
fertility change to any of the
standard socioeconomic
variables.
Now the word socioeconomic,
I think, is a terrible word.
What is not either socio or
economic?
I always go around and ask
people descriptions of it and I
think it basically means
anything you can quantify,
and you get interesting
variables like education and
we'll see this sort of
disastrously from understanding
the situation when we come into
the third world.
Education suits you for a
better job,
especially women,
so when people get educated
it's an economic variable
because it suits you for a
better job,
you can get higher pay,
it makes it more worth your
while to go out and work than
stay home and have children.
But, education also gives you a
window on the world and makes
you more open to new ideas,
a greater sense of agency that
you can talk back to your
husband or your mother-in-law,
and so forth,
so a lot of the variables--
you can't decide is this an
economic variable or a social
variable?
It's very unfortunate that they
use this term socioeconomic
variable.
But, I think it was early stage
in understanding the problem and
they didn't know what to do
about it.
Also another problem,
it's always in the social
sciences when you try to do
these studies,
getting the data itself is
really very difficult.
Since Europe is organized
politically into provinces
that's where the data was
gathered and that's--
they had province level things,
they didn't have individual
village level information,
family kind of information.
When you do an aggregation,
even as finely as they could
do,
I mean it's amazing to do every
province in Europe so that was
for the--
for that period of social
science that was the low level
of aggregation,
but still within each province
you have a huge range of people
in very different circumstances,
and maybe you're missing a lot
by this aggregation,
so aggregation is a problem.
Since this period a lot of
social science scholars have
come back and argued
tremendously over this and
saying,
'no there really are economic
reasons for fertility decline,'
and we'll talk about those in a
later lecture.
I just want to summarize--we
spent a lot of time on this
demographic transition and it's
theory,
and a lot of reading--and every
year students say,
'oh I hated that part of the
course,' but it is in a sense
the most--
for the modern times it's the
most important part of the
course because everything else
that you read,
every understanding of the
what's happening now in
developing countries is based on
this stuff,
either agrees with it or
disagrees with it,
or uses the same methodology or
very self consciously tries to
use a different methodology,
this is the foundation of the
fields.
That's one reason you should
know about it.
The other is it's such a
tremendous change,
it may be to my mind,
it's the most important
revolution ever in human
history.
Look what happens throughout
this period.
Life, people get to live three
times as long,
imagine if you're at 20,
how many of you are under 20?
Okay, half of you would be
dead, half of this class would
be dead if we weren't--if we
hadn't gone through this
transition of modernization.
He's happy about that.
The numbers of human beings,
the number of people that we
now are able to keep alive is
ten times larger,
everyday it gets bigger,
but last time I counted ten
times larger than what we think
the population was back then.
So an enormous--even though
it's the introduction of
contraception which limits the
amount of people or tries to
limit the amount of people.
In fact, the number of people
on earth has just expanded
enormously, both in numbers and
in how long each one lives.
Wealth, individual per capita
wealth,
we saw that the industrial
revolution by itself got into
Malthusian problems and didn't,
at least up until the fertility
transition,
did not improve people's
individual wealth.
That required the combination
of industrial revolution which
increased production and
fertility control which put a
limit on the number of people
trying to get advantage from
that increased production.
We've seen a tremendous
democratization of marriage.
Imagine a society where 30%
of--70% of the people are
unmarried,
we sort of talk a lot about
marriage and how marriage is
going away as an institution.
We're way, way ahead of that.
China is way ahead of that and
so imagine there was that--
very few of you would have
prospects of ever getting
married because society just
didn't allow it and the same for
sex as I've mentioned,
the democratization of sex.
Your fertility coming under
your individual control,
what a big change in life,
that you, now it's one of the
big decision you can make.
Do I want some children,
many children,
few children,
whatever, when do I want them?
All this comes under control.
Within marriage,
previously couples were
constantly under the pressure of
constant childbearing,
that the wife was always either
pregnant or lactating.
Later I'll show you some
statistics from the third world
that women are almost never
free, they're always either
pregnant or lactating until they
die.
Men had to go out--this is a
period when men were basically
the breadwinners.
They had to support an ever
increasing number of children
under difficult economic
circumstances.
So men and women were freed
from the requirement--
they had no choice--the
requirement of supporting,
taking care of and supporting
these large families.
There's so many issues that
changed during this time.
If you--if any of you are
thinking of doing term papers
there's just an infinite number
of things that have not even
been looked at.
For instance,
we talked a lot about
abandonment of children,
infanticide.
When do you think that
disappeared?
Something in about this time;
you read about it into the
1800s there was a lot of it and
then it goes away.
There's a lot written about the
period when it was heavy and not
much understanding of why did
infanticide disappear.
Was it due to this?
I don't know the answer;
I don't think it has been
discovered;
investigated,
a great term paper.
What about the romantic
conception of marriage?
When marriage changes like this
it becomes less of an economic
thing,
less of a childbearing thing,
you don't need your wife to
work,
especially on the farm.
What is the tie in between
romantic conceptions that we all
now have about marriage and love
and all that and this whole
demographic transition?
In almost every way you can
think of modern culture,
this is at the root of it,
that this is a thing that you
always have to consider as
whatever you believe,
however you're leading your
life, how much of it is due to
these pioneers that we've talked
about that started controlling
their fertility as an individual
decision rather than as a
community decision?
Okay, there's no reading for
today because the lecture is now
caught up for the reading,
so next week we'll talk on
Tuesday and then on Thursday we
have a guest lecturer.
The schedule changed from what
you have.